so Greg let's talk a little bit about
reverse dieting ooh my favorite so a
quick question what does reverse dieting
do
oh man
um so
you know I think it I think it's good
for uh reversing metabolic damage for
building up my metabolic capacity
helping me maintain weight on a higher
total calorie intake helping me maintain
a higher calorie intake the next time I
cut so I can get leaner easier stay
leaner longer without much of an issue
um those are all of the things that I've
been led to believe that it does and I
will be very disappointed if it turns
out that maybe it doesn't do some of
those things
yeah so with those claims uh of the
volumes of research supporting all of
them do you recall a single study
showing anything in that General
ballpark you know this isn't my area
this isn't the type of research that I
personally keep up to date with but due
to the volume of claims being made about
it and the the confidence behind the
claims being made about it I have to
assume that there is a lot of high
quality very strong data supporting it
that would be I'll also be very
disappointed if I find out that that's
not the case yeah that's a reasonable
assumption but in this segment we're
going to dig into it a little bit okay
so we're going to talk about reverse
dieting we're going to talk about
a lot of the claims that are made about
it and digging into the evidence which
um doesn't the evidence is far less
exciting than a lot of the claims in
hype surrounding reverse dieting so
we're going to dig into the details here
but you know before I get into it I want
to kind of explain the backdrop here the
history a little bit so
since about 2013
I have been chewing on a general set of
related topics in my research in my blog
posts and just in my own life right so
one of the first things uh that got me
interested in these topics was my own
experiences as an athlete and as a coach
um as a two-sport professional athlete
much like Bo Jackson
uh so the general set of topics is
metabolic adaptation weight regain after
diets and both short-term and long-term
weight regulation uh and it's not hard
to figure out how I got there I I used
to be a wrestler transitioned into
natural bodybuilding and there's this
psych you know the cyclical process
by which you get very very lean for a
competition you regain weight you get
very very lean again and there are so
many physiological adaptations and
perturbations that occur throughout that
series of changes so
um that's what got me into this in 2013
the first time I ever published about
this set of Concepts was 2014 in the
peer-reviewed literature and uh to the
best of my knowledge one of my papers
was the first to actually use the term
reverse dieting in the peer-reviewed
literature so this is a topic I've been
following closely since that paper was
that paper was published in 2014 was but
was being written back in 2013. so I've
been keeping my ear to the ground do you
think I mean just for for the listeners
the viewers uh do you think that that
might potentially be a source of bias
where you know you you might stand to
benefit from all of this research you're
about to tell us about for how effective
reverse dieting is the fact that you
were the the first person to talk about
it in the literature you know all of
this support for reverse dieting that
you're about to tell us about kind of
makes you look good in hindsight so do
you do you think you need to disclose
that conflict of interest
so yeah the conflict of interest is that
uh you know
as a researcher the only way for me to
really benefit from reverse dieting is
by asserting oh this definitely works
right like I was the first person that
introduced this into the literature I'm
going to try to take credit for that and
that's going to make me look like
someone who was really ahead of the
curve in the research right uh another
potential conflict of interest is hey we
sell a diet app we sell diet uh you know
products and content Etc whatever the
case is uh we're in this industry right
so absolutely it would be beneficial for
us to say hey everyone's excited about
reverse dieting let's make some cash
let's profit off of that excitement so
the conflict of interest argument would
on all accounts say Eric it benefits you
to say that reverse dieting absolutely
lives up to the hype and is very very
worthwhile
um as we're going to get into though
I am unable to to make any such
evidence-based claim that reverse
dieting lives up to basically any of the
hype that surrounds it wait what yeah I
know so I need to strap in exactly so
you'll want to take a seat this is
spooky uh you know you can leave the
room if you need a minute to gather your
thoughts uh and regain your composure
but I I think it's best that we probably
just dive into the evidence and kind of
get into it so do it
um you know in recent years reverse
dietings become really really popular uh
in some areas of of the dieting world
and the Fitness World
um and what we want to do is basically
figure out
doesn't have supporting evidence is it
at least compatible with the most
relevant evidence available and also are
there potentially some more parsimonious
explanations for the positive anecdotes
that we see on social media there are a
lot of people who say I've done reverse
dieting and it worked great for me you
should try it too but you know one of
the foundational elements of Science and
by extension evidence-based practice is
a general preference for parsimony right
so if there's a set of observations uh
you know we could say oh this is a
completely novel thing that's never been
discovered and we don't understand and
it's never been seen in the literature
yet but the literature will keep up
eventually or catch up yeah you know we
would much prefer to say oh I can very
much explain that set of observations
with a very tidy explanation that's
based on fairly straightforward
mathematical explanations and stuff
we've already seen in the literature
like that would be preferable if both
lend an equal amount of support for the
topic right
so uh as you mentioned reverse dieting
often touted as a remedy for metabolic
adaptation and as a strategy to
facilitate easier and more sustainable
weight loss
um could you uh just hit us with a rough
operational definition of metabolic
adaptation just for just for people who
who haven't listened to the show before
absolutely if this is your first time
listening to this show that you've never
heard of metabolic adaptation
um so the general idea is we start
dieting right we're restricting energy
we're in a calorie deficit or negative
energy balance which means that our
daily energy expenditure is greater than
our daily energy intake right so that
helps us start losing weight we're in
this energy deficit where we're in
negative energy balance and as we're
doing that we start to lose fat tissue
right and so metabolic adaptation
describes uh kind of an entire
cluster of adaptations that occur as a
person continues on that weight loss
trajectory so their total energy
expenditure goes down which would be
expected when you go from being a larger
person to a smaller person
you will burn fewer calories on a daily
basis with no adaptation required you
just have less tissue yeah if there's 20
percent less of me it takes 20 percent
less energy to to locomote myself around
the world right so so we expect that
energy expenditure should go down to
some extent but metabolic adaptation
describes uh an Adaptive reduction in
energy expenditure so energy expenditure
goes down more than we should have
predicted based on the loss of tissue
and what's really happening is it's kind
of like putting your phone on low
battery mode right where you basically
tell your phone like hey I haven't
charged you in a while resources are
tight so all the extra stuff you
normally do in the background let's try
to get as efficient as possible and
minimize energy usage right so that's in
a very simplistic sense what's going on
we're conserving energy to essentially
try to prevent further weight loss
because if we let weight loss go on
forever with no friction at all we call
that starvation in the biology business
right so we have an interest in trying
to introduce some friction there
because our bodies can't tell that we're
getting ready for a bodybuilding show
they think we're starving to death yeah
you know and so the hypothalamus is a
key brain structure that is
orchestrating metabolic adaptation which
involves not just a reduction in energy
expenditure but a lot of the unpleasant
side effects that we associate with
dieting so if you look at the metabolic
adaptation literature there's clear
parallels to what we call relative
energy deficiency in sport or relative
energy deficiency and it's this whole
cluster of things that happens when when
energy availability gets low right so we
might have low libido we might see that
testosterone and thyroid hormone go down
we buy might be more lethargic more
hungry it's just this entire set of
adaptations that is all in response to
acute and chronic restriction of energy
the hypothalamus is dictating this and
ultimately leptin is a key signal signal
that is telling the hypothalamus leptin
being a hormone
that's produced in fat cells leptin is
relaying the signal to the hypothalamus
energy is tight you need to shut some
things down and very importantly there
are two things that cause pretty
substantial perturbations in leptin
levels number one would just be being in
an energy deficit so acute energy
restriction reduces leptin the second
thing is the loss of fat tissue so as
fat cells start to shrink over time they
produce less leptin so it's very clear
in all the the literature that being in
an energy deficit independently
contributes to metabolic adaptation and
this reduction in energy expenditure but
also the loss of fat tissue over the
long term also has an independent
contribution okay so that's critically
important so the theory with reverse
dieting
is that basically increasing your
calories very slowly and systematically
and methodically can reverse metabolic
adaptation in some of these other
symptoms of dieting so the idea is if
you just start slowly increasing your
calories your body will say oh there's
some more energy here enough for me to
turn off low battery mode but not enough
for me to decide to store any fat in the
process or any appreciable amount of fat
in the process so a lot a lot of folks
use reverse dieting say well I want to
get back to how I used to feel before
the diet I want to get back to what my
energy expenditure was before the diet
because it's gone down a lot but I don't
want to regain much if any of the weight
that was lost so so the idea then would
be that these slow calorie increases are
going to dramatically increase daily
energy expenditure they are going to be
very carefully matched to your total
daily energy expenditure as you go such
that you're able to ramp energy
expenditure up and stop feeling so
lethargic and get your hormone levels
back to normal
and you're doing all of this stuff
essentially in the absence of fat gain
or with extremely minimal fat regain
that's the theory behind it and so it
gives rise to a number of common claims
so people will say it fixes a damaged
metabolic rate people will say that you
know that metabolic adaptation is
essentially making it almost impossible
for you to lose any more weight and you
need a reverse diet so that you can
become able again to even have the hope
of losing more weight in the future
right so there's a two-fold claim there
one is that metabolic adaptation which
is sometimes claimed as like starvation
mode or metabolic damage the first claim
is that that is a completely
insurmountable road block to further
weight loss or just maintaining weight
loss after your diet's done the second
part of the claim is that this is
actually reversed and fixed by reverse
dieting
um along those lines you'll see claims
that reverse dieting will fix any of
those hormone changes that that occur
during weight loss in addition to
ramping up metabolic rate in some cases
people will take this a step further and
not just say oh reverse dieting will get
you back to your original Total daily
energy expenditure at this lower body
weight some people even say forget about
it whatever weight you're at this is
going to supercharge your metabolic rate
such that your energy expenditure is
higher than you've ever experienced in
the past like you are going to tap into
a physiological state that you have not
previously reached in your life
um and one of the biggest claims one of
the biggest selling points that you see
among reverse dieting proponents is
you're doing this to lay the foundation
for a better future you are super
charging and building up your metabolic
rate and energy expenditure because
that's going to make your next diet
easier or it's going to make it way
easier to sustain weight loss in the
long run the idea being
you're going to you used to have to get
down to 1700 calories a day to
effectively diet now you're only going
to have to go down to 2100 calories a
day to effectively diet and you're going
to get just as lean in the same amount
of time that's usually how it goes so
there's a lot of questions that come up
here in this segment I'm going to try to
concisely go through and answer those
questions based on actual scientific
evidence not just like theorizing and
anecdotes and stuff like that before I
get into it I want to acknowledge what
I'm trying to do here is break down a
60-page article
into like a 20-ish minute segment which
I'm sure I'll go long on so don't even
check the time stamps you're absolutely
going to go long but I I think this will
still be audio visual gold yeah so just
just take the time you need yeah but but
I do want to acknowledge if if you're
hearing this and saying yeah that sounds
like the cliff notes but I want the real
stuff
um we are going to have uh By the time
this episode airs the article should be
live over at macrofactorapp.com
and like I said it's like 60 pages in
its current form and it's going to
provide all the references that you hear
in this segment and provide even more
detail uh so if you're into that be sure
to check out the link in the show notes
and if you're wondering why the show
notes don't have like 38 studies
referenced it's because I'm going to
link to the article and say Here's Where
they are okay so some questions that I
want to address by looking at the
evidence do metabolic rates get damaged
because damage is a pretty serious his
word damage seems to imply to me that
there is effort required to fix right so
do metabolic rates get damaged in a
really substantial and persistent way
do low metabolic rates play a major role
in preventing weight loss or promoting
weight regain
does reverse dieting actually resolve
the effects of metabolic adaptation
does reverse dieting supercharge your
metabolic rate uh especially after a
diet does reverse dieting immediately
after a weight loss phase prevent weight
regain or facilitate a smoother
transition into what we would call a
maintenance phase where you're just
maintaining the weight loss that you
achieved uh does reverse dieting make
your next weight loss phase easier and
if reverse dieting doesn't fix metabolic
adaptation which we actually do about it
so that kind of sets the stage for what
we're going to talk about here uh and
with that with that out of the way uh
let's dig into some of the evidence here
so the first thing I want to address is
metabolic adaptation versus metabolic
damage right so metabolic adaptation
based on all the research that's been
done is a temporary State and if you
want to know how to reverse it it's
extremely easy to to do that and there's
ample evidence showing metabolic
adaptation being first what it takes is
twofold the first step is getting out of
an energy deficit so going from negative
energy balance to either neutral or
positive that that eliminates the kind
of immediate element that's driving
metabolic adaptation but there is that
second element
like I said metabolic adaptation is
being driven by an energy deficit and a
loss of fat Mass so there's ample
evidence that metabolic adaptation is
very easily reversed and what it takes
is getting out of the energy deficit and
regaining the fat that was lost
and I know that that's not what a lot of
people want to hear because you'd love
to say well I wish the first part would
take care of all of it but based on the
evidence that doesn't seem to be the way
that it works it definitely looks like
there's I'm going to show a figure here
from a great review paper by dulu who's
done a lot of really excellent work on
weight regain after weight loss and
based on the evidence available it's
very clear that uh there there's there's
really four things going on with weight
regain after a diet
so if you go from negative energy
balance to neutral or positive you are
going to eliminate the non-specific part
of adaptive thermogenesis which is which
is in some ways Anonymous with metabolic
adaptation it adaptive thermogenesis is
only looking at the energy expenditure
component of metabolic adaptation so
what we see is that in the weight regain
process getting out of a deficit
immediately influences energy
expenditure it doesn't fully restore it
to Baseline it just moves it up a little
bit to where it was at the end of the
diet right and then there's clearly an
impact where regaining fat is going to
be part of the process for fully
restoring energy expenditure to its
initial level but there's also two other
important regulatory factors in in the
weight regain process
one pertains to energy partitioning and
what the research would indicate is that
until you get back up to a body fat
percentage that is kind of similar ish
to where you started you are going to
preferentially regain fat rather than
muscle
so it's not like this perfectly linear
thing where you regain both at these
completely similar rates usually what
happens is you regain a lot of fat Mass
early in the weight regain process and
then lean mass starts to catch up much
later there's a preferential regain of
fat at the beginning and another
important thing is hyperphasia which
basically describes this really
excessive level of hunger that we
experience during especially very
aggressive dieting that hyperphasia
doesn't seem to really chill out until
you've regained all of the lean mass
that you lost during the diet right so
there's a very robust body of literature
telling us you know what is dictating
these things we experience during weight
loss and what it takes to restore them
and uh quite frankly there's there's not
a lot of room in this literature to
suggest that reverse dieting offers you
a path out that doesn't involve you know
this process of rest storing some fat
mass and ultimately regaining a a pretty
decent amount of weight both in the
forms of fat mass and fat free Mass
right so metabolic adaptation just to
kind of put a bow on this part uh
definitely a temporary state with
various different drivers and full
restoration of total daily energy total
daily energy expenditure is something
that based on the evidence is going to
require uh some degree of fat regain in
the process so just to be clear you're
saying people can lose weight and they
certainly can maintain weight loss like
we're not trying to play into the myth
of all diets fail everyone always
regains the weight they lose it's just
if you do lose a pretty substantial
amount of weight and fat Mass you should
anticipate over the pretty long term uh
at least some degree of reduction in in
metabolic rate and total daily energy
expenditure right yeah yeah that would
be correct
um now that that leads me to an
important point though which is that we
you know we've talked about some of
these uh drivers of metabolic adaptation
and what it takes to fully reverse all
elements of metabolic adaptation 100 but
a really important question is are we
sure that we actually need to fully
avoid metabolic adaptation even if it
were possible or completely reverse it
you know how impactful is metabolic
adaptation when it comes to weight loss
and weight regain uh so I'm gonna put
some images on on the the screen if
you're following Along on YouTube uh but
there's been a really a series of
studies here so there's a study by
Martins and colleagues where they're
looking at okay uh how much does
metabolic adaptation impact an
individual's ability to actually lose
weight during an intervention what they
found is participants lost about 14
kilograms on average that's a
substantial weight loss said that was
like 13 of their body weight uh the
typical uh metabolic adaptation as they
Quantified it was a about a 92 calorie
reduction per day and what they found
was yes people who experienced more
metabolic adaptation did lose less
weight over the course of this
intervention but what they found was an
increase in metabolic adaptation of 50
calories a day was associated with a
lower weight loss of only half a
kilogram and so just purely based on the
numbers there
is very clear to see that even the
people who experience pretty substantial
metabolic adaptation you would still
look at this and say you had a very
successful weight loss diet here you
know and that just to put that number in
perspective the 92 calories that that's
disproportionate reductions in resting
metabolic rate not total daily energy
expenditure right disproportionate
relative to predicted looking at resting
energy expenditure so the the
presumably the reductions in total daily
energy expenditure were probably larger
right yes yeah yeah
um but but what this is telling us is
using uh metabolic adaptation looking at
the resting metabolic rate component
basically just as a means of kind of
sorting okay who was really experiencing
it uh versus who wasn't you know that
that's really the the utility there
rather than quantifying the total impact
in terms of calories per day but what
they're able to see is just like the
folks who were experiencing more
metabolic adaptation in this study still
had very successful weight loss programs
it just it they just didn't lose quite
as much during during the the program
right so it's not like they hit a brick
wall they just had a little bit more
friction along the way uh there's also a
study a different study by Martins and
colleagues
where they were looking at the time to
reach a weight loss goal and in this
particular cohort weight loss on average
was 12 and a half kilograms uh average
weight loss time was 155 days again they
found that folks who experienced more
metabolic adaptation it did take them a
little longer to get to their weight
loss goal but for each 10 calorie
increase in metabolic adaptation
kilocalories per day the time to reach
their weight loss goal increased by a
single day right so when you're talking
about that number and you're looking at
in this cohort average metabolic
adaptation was Quantified as 46 calories
per day again the people experiencing
metabolic adaptation were still you
would you would look at their progress
and say you are succeeding here you are
doing great you might just need a little
bit of extra time to get to where you're
going yeah right it's like even in an
extreme case like
if if other people would need to diet
for three months even with pretty
extreme metabolic adaptation like you
should you should still be able to get
the job done in four months yeah so so
what these studies are showing us is
that with metabolic adaptation even if
you're experiencing it uh much more than
the average individual you should still
be there's still a very clear path
between you and your goal it might just
require slightly greater reductions in
calorie intake or alternatively just a
slightly longer dieting timeline this is
friction but it's not an insurmountable
roadblock right uh another study by
Martins and colleagues this group has
been doing a ton of work in this area
over the last few years uh they they
found that metabolic adaptation was not
a substantial barrier when it comes to
uh long-term maintenance of weight loss
so they actually looked at over a one to
two year follow-up period uh metabolic
adaptation was found on average after
weight loss again about on the 54
calorie per day range but this didn't
really correlate with people's
likelihood of regaining weight over the
next two years there are much more
important predictors of weight regain
that really have nothing to do with
metabolic rate or metabolic adaptation
it usually comes down to are you
continuing to monitor your health
related behaviors and your weight
related behaviors are you continuing to
track your food keeping your activity
level up uh you know continuing to
monitor body weight so as it starts
creeping up you can then address it
before it gets you know starts to really
accumulate so they're a much more
impactful predictors of weight regain
than anything to do with metabolic
metabolic rate or metabolic adaptation
uh and then there's also an interesting
study by uh father Gill and colleagues
they were looking at metabolic
adaptations six years after the Biggest
Loser competition which I resent almost
everything about the Biggest Loser
competition it's unsustainable it's it's
not good uh but one of the Silver
Linings is that there was good research
done surrounding uh The Biggest Loser uh
competition which if you're not familiar
it was like a TV show with this
extremely aggressive weight loss
intervention
um and yeah the intervention like I said
I'm not really a huge fan of how it was
done and how it was portrayed yeah as a
television program but uh nonetheless
there was some good research that came
of it
um what they found was that after this
30-week intervention the amount of
metabolic adaptation that you
experienced and there was a tremendous
magnitude in this study because of how
extreme the intervention was after the
weight loss period that metabolic
adaptation
didn't really correlate much at all with
your likelihood of regaining weight
what they did find was that people who
still had metabolic adaptation present
at the six year follow-up were actually
the people who very successfully
prevented weight regain so right after
the diet metabolic adaptation was not
predictive of future weight regain at
the follow-up period metabolic
adaptation was essentially a marker of
success for reducing weight regain
because if you regain the weight the
metabolic adaptation goes away as we've
already kind of covered so what this
research shows us
you know and there's actually even a
better study I would say there's a study
by rimbach and colleagues that was
published just this year as part of that
huge doubly labeled water database and
we've been talking about they've been
cranking out really high impact papers
from that uh just in terms of their
utility was that the same database that
the the ponzer study about uh metabolic
rates across the lifespan where that
came from yes okay yeah so that database
and the projects surrounding it have
really helped clarify a lot of things
about metabolism and energy expenditure
and there was one recent paper that came
out this year and they were basically
interested in figuring out like is low
total daily energy expenditure
a risk factor for weight gain and and
similarly is high you know total daily
energy expenditure is this actually
protective against future weight gain
like what is looking at someone's energy
expenditure tell us about their current
body composition in terms of predictive
utility and what is likely to happen in
future weeks
um and what they found using gold
standard measurement techniques is that
uh essentially looking at someone's
total daily energy expenditure now
um doesn't really tell you a ton about
what their body composition is likely to
be and looking at how their total daily
energy expenditure changes over time
doesn't really tell you much about you
know how how their body composition is
going to change and actually what they
found some of their analyzes were
basically null findings and said yeah
energy expenditure doesn't give us a lot
of actionable information here the the
only correlations they found were
actually the opposite of what reverse
dieting would imply
so looking at uh adjusted values for
total daily energy expenditure they
found that higher and like increasing
values for this adjusted total daily
energy energy expenditure value was
actually correlated with weight gain
over the time frame studied so what they
I'll read the quote here what they
concluded this suggests that low energy
expenditure total daily energy
expenditure is not a risk factor for uh
and high total daily energy expenditure
is not protective against weight or body
fat game body fat gain over the time
intervals tested so basically this idea
that you need to reverse diet so that
you have this high energy expenditure
that you know induces future weight loss
or prevents weight regain after dieting
it doesn't seem to be compatible with
what we're seeing here and even just the
the purpose statement of well you need
reverse dieting because metabolic
adaptation just slams the brakes on your
weight loss again
we're not really seeing those types of
claims supported by the literature yeah
I I think that um
I think one thing that may be helpful
just to like talk about and clarify is
that
I think it's I think it's very easy and
tempting to test theoretical
counterfactuals about yourself that did
not in fact occur and so by that I mean
um so like like personally I have a
relatively low rate of total daily
energy expenditure relative to both my
size and activity levels
um like I'm eating like a little under 2
000 calories per day to lose weight very
gradually and I'm I'm like low 220s and
relatively active people hear that and
they're like
that's that's crazy like that seems way
lower than it should be and it might be
easy for me to look at that
and say man if I had a higher rate of
total daily energy expenditure it would
be a lot easier for me to lose weight
but the thing is like I don't know that
uh and also like a lot of the difficulty
comes from like how how the the hunger
cues you have and how you respond to
them yeah and people will hear like
people who are smaller than me will hear
oh you're under 2 000 calories a day at
your size man if I had to go that low I
would be super hungry all the time but
the thing is like I'm not like I I feel
generally fine because to some degree to
some degree like hunger responses are
kind of tuned to how much energy you're
actually expending yeah and so if I was
burning 500 more calories per day in
eating 500 more calories per day
um if I look at that assuming that my
feelings consuming 2500 calories per day
in that City situation would be the same
as they currently feel now I'd be oh I'd
be like oh that would make things so
much easier but if I was burning 500
more calories per day I'd probably feel
the same on 2500 calories as I currently
do on 2000 yeah and so like those are
those are counter factuals that you
can't test within an individual and it's
it's always easy to think man if I could
if I could just eat more this weight
loss diet would be so much easier than
it currently is but if you were someone
who could eat more that would mean you
were also burning more
and that might not actually make the
process all that much easier yeah the
the
um that pairing between your intake and
expenditure is much more impactful for
how you're feeling in that process than
just the raw absolute numbers of
calories consumed yeah for sure
um now one of the things I want to get
at here so we've talked about how
generally speaking energy expenditure
just measured kind of randomly at
Baseline doesn't really seem to tell us
much about like how lean you're likely
to be or how your weight is likely to
change over the next several weeks
um you know nonetheless I'm sure that a
lot of people are still thinking well
whatever I'll take my chances I want to
do something that may supercharge my
metabolic rate because I have faith that
once I do my next diet I'm going to feel
way better dieting on higher calories
but built into that
is the assumption that everyone
experiences the same change when you go
from your Baseline starting calories to
negative energy balance in a diet right
so it's almost like everyone assumes
well whoever starts the diet with 2100
calories is going to be able to die on
higher calories than someone who starts
the diet at 1900 calories right like
it's it's all going to be this like
perfectly linear transformation right
and unfortunately the literature casts
an extreme amount of Doubt on that so
there have been two recent studies uh
one by Nunes and colleagues one by
halstein and colleagues and what they
were interested in was looking at the
concept of metabolic phenotypes right
and so a phenotype is broadly speaking
kind of like a set of observable
characteristics and in this case we're
talking about a set of observable
characteristics that allow us to kind of
group People based on how they react to
energy right so some people are very
good at saving and conserving energy and
these people when they diet they
experience large magnitudes magnitudes
of metabolic adaptation so they start
they they get into an energy deficit and
their body is like no we're conserving
energy let's drop energy expenditure
because of that drop in calorie intake
these folks are also good at conserving
energy on the other side of the spectrum
if they start eating more calories they
very readily store fat because that's
the most efficient thing to do energy
wise there are also people on the other
end of the spectrum who are spendthrift
metabolic phenotypes what that means is
they're very uh wasteful of energy
so when they start dieting and they get
into negative energy balance they don't
experience such large metabolic
adaptations they don't experience big
drop-offs in energy expenditure but if
you overfeed them they ramp up energy
expenditure very precipitously very
rapidly and they're actually very
resistant to Fat gain there have been
interesting studies where they take
people into the lab and say everyone's
eating 40 percent more calories than
they need for the next eight weeks right
this huge amount of overfeeding
consistently well controlled and what
they find is some people gain a ton of
fatness and some people simply don't
some of these spend Thrift individuals
just ramp up energy expenditure and they
resist that that weight gain there's
nothing mysterious about it you can look
at their energy expenditure and say well
that's that's where the calories went
you know but there's a clear difference
they're just sitting in their their
chair basically vibrating yeah yeah so
so there's there's no mystery involved
here we can see some people are more
likely to ramp up energy expenditure
when overfed and they resist fat gain
other people much more energy efficient
if you put in energy they say cool I'll
store it for later no big deal now the
reason that this is important is because
all of the people who think it's cool to
be able to easily diet down to the point
where you have visible ABS that's cool
and all but I mean when Human Society
falls apart and we're all fighting over
resources
it's people like me who are going to be
on the top of the Heap and that's that's
all I'm saying yeah that is very true
yeah uh be careful what you wish for I
suppose correct
um so with Nunes and Holstein both of
these studies were interested in looking
at metabolic phenotypes and so Holstein
looked at acutely you know the people
who experience large reductions in
energy expenditure uh during very
short-term underfeeding and overfeeding
so for example if we just have you fast
for a day who has an enormous drop in
energy expenditure and who has a much
smaller drop in energy expenditure Nunez
and colleagues looked at it very
differently and looked over a longer
intervention who seems to be resisting
fat loss versus who seems to be losing
fat quite readily and and very
effectively right so the people who are
clearly reducing energy expenditure and
preserving fat despite the fact that
they're trying to lose it over time
so what's really cool about these
studies is they they look at different
time scales but they're still separating
people into these Thrifty and spend
Thrift groups
uh but here's what the results indicate
in both cases the people who were
considered Thrifty uh the people who are
good at conserving energy you would say
you would probably assume well at
Baseline they probably already had low
energy expenditure because these are
just energy efficient folks not the case
actually the complete opposite of the
case in both instances
the evidence would suggest that people
who experience the greatest amount of
metabolic adaptation
and by extension the people who
experience smaller increases in energy
expenditure when their calories go up
these people had higher energy
expenditure at Baseline compared to the
spendthrift individuals and so what this
means is and this is critically
important and in my opinion
the one of the most important reasons
that I am doubtful of reverse dieting
would you maybe say that they had high
metabolic capacity at Baseline but still
experienced metabolic damage as soon as
they got into a deficit exactly yeah so
even if you said I believe reverse
dieting works as advertised literally
uh
the whole idea there is like oh well
yeah ramp up your metabolic rate and
that went that way when you start your
diet energy expenditure will be higher
and it'll be way easier next time around
what the evidence tells us is that
people who experience more considerable
metabolic adaptation their energy
expenditure is higher right before they
start that diet they already have that
higher metabolic capacity the issue is
not that they're starting at the wrong
number the issue is that when they go
into a deficit they experience a larger
drop and there's absolutely and I can't
overstate this
no evidence to suggest that reverse
dieting would change that in any way
there is no reason to believe that even
if you built up your energy expenditure
in the off season and said okay uh I
built up my energy expenditure it's time
to diet if you're the kind of person who
would actually need this intervention
more than a spendthrift individual there
is no reason to believe that your energy
expenditure is not going to drop the
same exact way the moment you start that
diet we have no reason to believe that
any buildup of metabolic capacity before
the diet will carry forward at all
and another important part there like I
said Thrifty individuals based on their
research experience smaller increases in
energy expenditure as their increase in
calorie intake so what that means is you
know the first part was we're granting
yes as you ramp up energy intake you're
going to ramp up energy expenditure so
the first issue is if you're someone who
experiences a lot of metabolic
adaptation
it's very very doubtful that that would
carry forward at all but the second
issue is before we even get there
someone who experiences larger
magnitudes of metabolic adaptation a
Thrifty individual is less likely to
even be able to ramp up through
deliberate over feeding so deliberately
increasing calorie intake as far as we
can tell the people who actually respond
to that and would see meaningful
increases in total daily energy
expenditure are people who are spend
Thrift individuals they don't even
experience really substantial metabolic
adaptation when they diet and these are
people who are are naturally quite lean
because of their innate resistance to
Fat gain and so what that tells us is
based on the evidence the people who
quote unquote need reverse dieting the
most assuming it actually did what it's
supposed to
stand to benefit the least it's very
unlikely that they're going to be able
to ramp up energy expenditure through
over feeding and even if they did that
probably doesn't matter because once
they get into a deficit they are based
on the evidence likely to experience a
substantial drop in energy expenditure
yeah
so
I know I'm running along so for some of
these parts I'm going to kind of Hit the
details and again refer people to the
full article for even more nuance and
explanation uh one art one piece of
evidence I do want to acknowledge is a
study by longstrom and colleagues which
is one of the few that actually Compares
people after a bodybuilding competition
who took a kind of reverse deity
approach versus people who just said
whatever I'm going to regain weight
pretty quickly here and the reason I
highlight this paper is essentially the
analysis showed a very straightforward
pattern and this was a case a case
Series so this is not like a randomized
controlled trial
this is not the type of thing where
you know you're going to be able to make
super super uh strong claims based on
you know the reverse diet versus
alternative strategies were not strictly
controlled by the research team and
things like that um but but basically
this was a study that I collaborated on
with some really excellent researchers
looking at uh physique athletes after a
competition who are just doing what they
what they think is best for themselves
right a very hands-off approach but the
statistical analysis showed some pretty
straightforward patterns where the the
folks who just let themselves regain
some weight and some fat Mass after the
show
um you know they they recovered quite
well from all that stuff that we would
kind of lump under that metabolic
adaptation umbrella so uh the hormone
changes the the metabolic rate changes
those were expedited by just saying you
know what I'm gonna go ahead and let
myself regain some weight uh the people
who appeared to try to keep body weight
pretty stable and just slowly ramp up
calorie intake
based on the measurements taken it seems
like that really interfered with the
recovery of hormone levels and the
recovery of metabolic rate and so
without painting with too broad of a
brush simply put in this study which is
the most direct evidence we have of
something that would be called reverse
dieting it just really fell flat it
seemed to really
delay recovery from an intense diet and
essentially failed to deliver on a lot
of those promises by which it's marketed
this idea that oh no it'll facilitate
recovery but you don't have to deal with
all that unwanted fat gain uh you know
these results directly oppose that
concept and suggest that the reluctance
to regain some weight in that process it
does in fact kind of stop some of that
recovery in its tracks yeah
um
now
just just take your time cover
everything you want to my segment ran
long as well
just you know what let's let's try to
make this as as good and thorough of a
piece of audio content as possible let's
not rush it yeah let's take our time
then so at this point just kind of
recapping metabolic adaptation exists
it's impermanent uh it does add some
friction to the weight loss process but
it does not make weight further weight
loss impossible nor does it guarantee
you're going to regain weight so that's
really important second of all we can
categorize people into these metabolic
phenotypes based on who experiences more
metabolic adaptation and who experiences
less what we know from that research is
that the folks who experience a lot of
metabolic adaptation which again does
add some friction and weight loss those
folks actually tend to have higher
energy expenditure at Baseline before
the weight loss diet begins so the idea
that they are struggling because they
didn't build up their metabolic capacity
is directly contradicted by the research
available
the research available would also
suggest that those folks even if they
wanted to increase calories to build up
their metabolic rate are actually least
likely to be able to do that because
they you know people who have this
Thrifty phenotype do not experience
these robust increases in energy
expenditure when their energy intake
starts to drift upward so what that
means is it doesn't look like building
up metabolic capacity is the problem in
the first place
it doesn't look like even if you did it
it would carry forward into the next
dieting phase it should basically just
vanish immediately when you start
dieting again and it's very unlikely
that the people who need it the most the
people who experience the greatest
metabolic adaptation would even be able
to do it because of that lack of
increase in energy expenditure during
overfeeding uh the idea that you can do
this reverse dieting to get all the
benefits of recovering from a previous
weight loss diet without weight gain or
without considerable weight gain is
actually directly contradicted by
evidence and directly contradicted by
the most relevant evidence that we have
available uh of course a randomized
controlled trial would be better but we
have to go with the evidence that we
have currently
uh the next thing I want to address is
kind of an extension of what I mentioned
previously so we've talked a little bit
about metabolic phenotypes and say well
okay the people who uh would be most
interested in building up metabolic
capacity through reverse dieting first
of all seem to have the least capacity
to do it but also have larger drops in
energy expenditure when they shift to a
diet anyway but another thing that is
important to ask yourself before that
before you even get into phenotypes is
well
who is actually interested in this
concept in the first place like who are
the people who are saying I need the
reverse diet because my I'm having
troubles with weight loss and the way
that I'm pursuing weight loss is
unsustainable it's usually people who
are
relatively predisposed to Fat gain in
the first place you know it it's very
rare that I hear someone who says yeah
I'm naturally very lean I have been all
my life uh but metabolic adaptation is
really holding me back here yeah someone
who can get in stage ready condition on
like 2 400 calories per day they're not
trying to reverse diet like they're
they're in pretty good shape yeah and so
that brings me to another point which is
related to metabolic phenotypes in a way
but you know what we find during
controlled over feeding studies is like
I said previously some people do
experience large increases in energy
expenditure and they very strongly
resist fat gain and I'll show an image
on the screen that that demonstrates
some of this data from Levine and
colleagues uh on the other hand a lot of
individuals experience minimal change in
energy expenditure and they very readily
and rapidly uh gain fat and so what that
tells us is
people who are likely to report a
history of struggling with weight loss
uh people who are likely to be pursuing
weight loss goals in the first place
um almost by definition are folks who
probably don't have this uh in this
context this advantage of being
resistant to Fat gain in the first place
it kind of gives us an indicator that
the people who are most interested in
exploiting this concept of reverse
dieting or utilizing it in their own uh
fitness journey they are probably not
these individuals who are in the
spendthrift phenotype who are resistant
to Fat gain in the first place so it
puts us in a position where based on all
the evidence we've covered so far that
people who are most interested
interested in using this again uh this
type of strategy even if it worked would
be least accessible to those individuals
uh those individuals
um
now moving on there's one additional
thing I want to mention here
in terms of over feeding
and that is the fact that a lot of these
overfeeding studies are are commonly
used to support claims about reverse
dieting they say well look at the group
level you you put these people in this
huge caloric Surplus and their energy
expenditure goes up therefore we're
going to build up your metabolic rate in
the off season right as I've already
covered that interpretation fully
ignores the concept of metabolic
phenotypes which is a major oversight
but an even bigger oversight is the fact
that it treats
just over feeding from a natural body
weight as if it's the same thing as
increasing calories after weight loss
yeah so when we look at weight reduced
individuals whether they lost their
weight five years ago or five days ago
being in a weight reduced state is a
unique physiological state so I
mentioned previously all of these
different factors that that occur with
with weight regain we talk about how
there's an immediate response when you
go from negative to neutral energy
balance right but it's not very
impactful until people get back to a
somewhat similar body fat level in the
weight regain process
there's ample tremendous amounts of
evidence to show that people
preferentially regain fat and they do
that very very efficiently so the fact
that you have previously lost weight
especially if it happened recently very
dramatically influences your response to
overfeeding even if you were someone who
might have experienced this adaptive
increase in energy expenditure
doing that after a weight loss phase is
exceedingly unlikely what we see in
virtually all of the weight regain
literature is that if you have
previously lost weight and you start
ramping calories up you will very
efficiently regain fat mass that has
been shown many many many different
times uh and so I'll put that I put that
image up previously with the Duluth
study where they they highlight an
entire body of literature indicating
that weight regain is a kind of unique
being in a weight reduced state is a
unique physiological State yeah
overfeeding after a diet is extremely
different physiologically than over
feeding from your natural body weight
and so this idea that we can just kind
of slowly ramp up calories and for some
reason
contrary to all the pre-existing
evidence your body is going to decide to
burn those calories rather than storing
uh it just it just contradicts volumes
of research on weight regain yeah it
reminds me of uh
I don't know how popular this still is
but maybe like three to five years ago
um it was a popular idea put forth in in
the bodybuilding community that after a
bodybuilding competition you were as
lean as you were ever going to get so
your your insulin sensitivity was as
high as it was ever going to get there
was going to be a huge nutrient
partitioning Advantage so if you started
over feeding from that point you'd be
able to gain a ton of muscle and
partially in support of that people
would cite a study by Forbes based on
over feeding research showing that in
general leaner people without a
resistance training stimulus you just
give them more calories they gain weight
but a larger proportion of the weight
they gain was lean mass versus people
with more body fat you over feed them a
larger proportion of the weight they
gain would be fat mass and they just
assumed that that would generalize but
the Forbes data was based on people who
were in neutral energy balance not in a
weight reduced State and then over fed
versus you know bodybuilders physique
athletes after a show very much in a
weight reduced State and so people were
putting forth this idea but all of the
controlled research all of the case
studies on bodybuilders and physique
athletes showed the exact opposite like
basically what you're saying when they
did overfeed to a large extent after a
show you know you would see a bump in
lean mass just from you know
body water glycogen resynthesis Etc but
mostly preferential fat gain and I think
that idea has lost some popularity in
recent years
I I think just because it didn't play
out in the real world like in in theory
people thought it made sense not
accounting for the fact that you know
weight neutral and weight reduced
individuals very different sets of of
like physiological bass lines there
um
and yeah like I I think I basically
think a lot of bodybuilders uh
especially like natural bodybuilders
tried to do that like oh I'm gonna get
shredded and then I'm gonna put on like
10 pounds of muscle as I rebound from
the show and like it just didn't work
out for any of them yeah and uh
so yeah like I I I think
the bodybuilding Community has started
to learn its lesson from that but yeah
the the basic principle extends to other
populations as well yeah I mean and we
see in in weight loss trials after
weight loss is achieved weight regain is
very common but it happens gradually
over time uh it seems hard to imagine
that whether we're looking at a
randomized controlled trial in an obese
population or we're looking at uh a
study in extremely lean physique
athletes I'm trying to find the instance
where if you just go slow enough like
over feeding just supercharges your
metabolic rate and you for some reason
don't regain fat the weight reduced
State makes us uh very efficient at
regaining fat and there's really no
evidence to suggest that simply going
slower is going to somehow Rectify or
circumvent that and actually that's a
really nice transition to a a good
example of that so
you mentioned previously proof of
concept studies um so you were talking
previously about uh calf stretching and
muscle growth and how sometimes we look
at a study that's the most extreme case
just to say okay if this is ever going
to work it's gonna work in this really
extreme instance yeah and then we can
refine it from there and see if it
matters in Practical day-to-day
strategies right so with that in mind
I'm going to lean on the Minnesota
starvation experiment and this was a
very extreme experiment where uh the the
participants in the study got very very
very lean so they demonstrated some of
the largest magnitudes of metabolic
adaptation that have ever been
documented in well-controlled research
so if a strategy about attenuating or
reversing metabolic adaptation was ever
going to work this was the study where
it ought to work and so a lot of people
say that they're going to use reverse
dieting because
for some reason after weight loss if you
simply go slow enough with your
increases in calories uh it will set you
up for a smoother transition to your
maintenance phase or attenuate weight
regain as you're doing that transition
so people often talk about this
experiment by keys and colleagues and
they often talk about the metabolic
adaptation component because it's flashy
and it's the biggest numbers ever uh
observed to my knowledge and it was kind
of the the first time that people said
whoa look at these crazy adaptations to
weight loss but there was a refeeding
component and there was a stratified
refeeding component so they put people
into these four different groups tgl and
z and they basically said okay group z
we're going to give you a much smaller
kind of transition into this refeeding
so smaller and slower calorie increases
uh
group L we're going to ramp you up
faster so bigger calorie increases more
more rapidly out of the gate Group G was
a little faster group T even faster and
what they looked at was there was this
controlled 12-week overfeeding period
and then a
non-controlled over feeding period after
that where they said okay now do your
thing and eat what you want you know
which is how we all live our lives right
so you know no one is like sitting there
like yeah I just finished my diet and
I'm waiting for some authority figure to
deliver my meals for the day because you
know all of my intake is perfectly
controlled at the end of the day real
world scenarios were all left to our own
devices there right but anyway in this
controlled over feeding period if you
look at the rate of weight gain in that
slow group uh they honestly didn't gain
an appreciation appreciable amount of
weight over the first six weeks of
refeeding uh which is remarkable because
again we're talking about out people
who were safely
on the brink of starvation I mean they
were close right it was monitored it was
medically supervised but these people
were shredded and they were not eating
much yeah and they're doing a lot of
activity as well this this was before
the Declaration of Helsinki right indeed
when you could still uh get away with
some [ __ ] and research that probably you
shouldn't exactly yeah so I mean they
basically stayed weight stable for the
first six weeks of controlled
overfeeding it was a very gradual thing
that I think you could argue is
relatively reminiscent of what people
suggest reverse dieting ought to look
like uh and so at the end of this
12-week period they started out the
first six weeks basically weight stable
and then it starts to creep up and
they've gained an appreciable amount of
weight by week 12 but there's very clear
gaps the slower uh refeeding groups
regained less weight over 12 weeks than
the faster refeeding groups because of
course they did they that's how numbers
work with calorie surpluses right yeah
the question is well what happens after
they go to the ad libitum stage where
they're able to eat whatever they want
and it you know they're left to their
own devices much like we are in the real
world the slower groups just regained
like they completely closed the Gap yeah
they very promptly went right back to
the same approximate body weight as the
folks who just gained it earlier and so
in this instance in the most extreme
application of metabolic adaptation
those short-term benefits of kind of
slowing the process over the first 12
weeks
they yielded virtually no benefit that
persisted beyond the next like couple
months uh once they were back to ad
libdum feeding
they very promptly basically caught up
with the fat gain of the other groups so
the other groups kind of trended they
kind of tapered off
um as we would anticipate based on what
we've talked about with fat Mass
dictating a lot of that process and the
groups that took it slower they just
caught up and they caught up very
quickly yeah so what we're seeing here
is that as I've stated previously the
people who are most interested in
Reverse dieting uh even if it worked it
would be less accessible to them but
based on the literature we really have
no reason to believe that it should work
or more importantly that it does work uh
it's it's not like there's evidence of
this working and we just haven't figured
out why yeah we know why it shouldn't
and we have also seen that if it did
it's just not happening in any of the
most well-controlled studies that are
most relevant yeah so it shouldn't work
based on what we know and based on what
we've observed it doesn't appear to work
yeah and I I I certainly acknowledge
that we haven't done a lot of direct
study on controlled reverse dieting
interventions but at this point it's
almost hard to justify doing it yeah uh
there's just not enough of a of a kernel
of optimism in the literature where you
would say this is a worthwhile thing
that we ought to do a huge randomized
controlled trial on that makes sense to
me but here's oh I'll do a little segue
for you wow so with all of that being
said it still seems like there are a lot
of people who have tried reverse dieting
and they they think it worked for them
so what might be going on in those
situations yeah so I believe that there
are four what I call illusions that make
reverse dieting in the real world in
practice seem more useful than it is and
before I get into it I do want to
acknowledge that uh what I'm doing here
is not doubting the experience of people
who have noted uh you know positive
experiences here
um you know it's really important to
clarify I'm not saying that uh you're
lying or you're misinterpreting what
what occurred
um well I guess I am saying you're
misinterpreting but uh basically I'm not
indicating that someone you're not
grossly and maliciously misinterpreting
right yeah I'm not saying oh you're full
of crap I'm not saying oh you're foolish
for being misled by these Illusions I'm
arguing that there are things that occur
during overfeeding that very
are they're very compelling Illusions if
you were doing it you would have every
reason to believe what I'm doing right
now is absolutely working as intended
yeah right you're you're reaching
incorrect but uh very very
understandable incorrect conclusions
absolutely these are conclusions that I
would not fault anyone for reaching or
sharing with excitement right so uh
illusion number one pertains to simply
just improved consistency of dietary
tracking and improved adherence to one's
dietary targets so if we look at the
literature we'll see that registered
dietitians who are I would say the most
well-trained nutrition profession in the
United States
but that's not really an arguable
statement they have the most Hands-On
direct training for what it's like you
know in day-to-day dietary uh
interventions or treatment programs
right so very well-trained nutrition
professionals they have about a 20 error
in the research when when you say okay
how much are you eating and then you
actually go verify how much they're
eating like they have a 20
underestimation of their actual energy
intake and again that's highly trained
folks eating the stuff they normally eat
just trying to do their normal thing not
trying to do any changes with Dynamic
targets fluctuating not trying to eat
Foods they're not used to that's just
like a baseline 20 underestimation when
we look at research in people who report
a history of
being unable to lose weight despite very
low calorie intakes we find that they
they often underestimate their calorie
intake by about 50 percent
while simultaneously overestimating
their physical activity Again by about
50 percent so we know that it's very
very common and understandable for
people to underestimate their intake
when they are not watching it like a
hawk right and so you introduce an
intervention like reverse dieting and in
many cases you have people saying well
the intervention here the magic
is that this week we're adding 5 grams
of carbs to your diet or 10 grams of
carbs to your diet
necessarily it insists upon a level of
consistency and precision with tracking
that in my opinion over the long term is
unsustainable but if nothing else makes
you say if I don't track every little
trace of my diet
I might lose the entire intervention
yeah right like if being off by 10 grams
turns it from an intervention to not an
intervention you must be perfect yeah
and so if we look at the magnitude of
common underestimation even in people
who are doing a pretty damn good job
with their tracking
it's not unreasonable to suggest that
some people will
find an extra few hundred calories when
they start tracking with this level of
precision
and what that means is someone will
think back to their a previous time
where they are at a similar body weight
and they say you know back then when I
was like kind of loosely doing a pretty
okay job tracking back then I was
maintaining this body at 2200 calories a
day but now I'm maintaining a very
similar body at 2600 calories per day so
my energy expenditure I've ramped it up
400 calories it's very possible that in
many cases you've simply identified the
extra 400 calories that historically
were not being consistently tracked
either because your day-to-day tracking
had some error or back then you didn't
think twice about finishing the kids
leftovers just to avoid food waste or
back then you didn't really worry about
the extra two beers on Saturday watching
the football game so we can find extra
calories through extremely precise
tracking that actually look very similar
to the purported increase in energy
expenditure with reverse dieting in some
of these anecdotes yeah uh illusion
number two is that practically speaking
a person's a person's maintenance
calorie Target is more like a range of
targets right
so for example if your true total daily
energy expenditure is 2200 calories a
day
uh and in this scenario we're going to
pretend it never changes it's totally
stable so eating 2200 calories every
single day should keep your body weight
totally flat in this hypothetical yeah
if you were to drop it to 2100 you would
be in 100 Calorie deficit
it would probably take you
a pretty long time to figure out that
you're actually losing weight right so
you're in 100 Calorie debt you're eating
a hundred calories below your actual
maintenance level but like if you just
crunch the numbers it should take you
over three months to lose a kilogram and
then you factor in the fact that every
day our body weight is constantly
bouncing up and down because of water
and sodium and glycogen and all that
crap and and the bulk content in our GI
tract so basically what I'm implying
here is that
for a lot of people
it might be hard without like some kind
of nice weight trending software and
without very diligent tracking it might
be really hard if you have a total daily
energy expenditure of 2200 calories a
day to actually know with any degree of
certainty that if you're eating 2 000
calories per day you're actually in a
deficit or if you're eating 2400
calories per day you're actually in a
surplus it could take you literally
months to figure that out and for it to
become apparent and that's assuming that
your your maintenance uh energy
expenditure is perfectly static correct
because I mean there there is like an
actual range on top of that yes like you
know your your maintenance range might
be 21 to 2300 calories so if you go down
to 21 you are still at maintenance like
your your need goes down a little bit
you're at that level it probably
wouldn't actually be reductions in
resting energy expenditure but you know
you like neat can adapt 200k calories
like pretty easily yeah um so yeah like
in in that case you know maybe you were
maintaining at
2000 or like 2100 before and now you get
up to 2300 it's like oh I built my
metabolic capacity no like both both of
those were already maintenance calorie
intakes in the first place you just kind
of found the top of that range yeah
which which might be nice but it's it's
not a unique adaptation correct and so
for a lot of people I do Wonder to what
extent some of these positive anecdotes
of of reverse dieting are people who
didn't really recognize that they were
either at the bottom of that range or
even in a small deficit and you know
they're just like oh yeah I guess I'm
maintaining weight approximately at 2
000 calories and then they don't really
realize that they're in a slight caloric
Surplus when they're at 2400 calories
and they say whoa I just increased my
energy expenditure 400 calories a day
and we can explain that uh pretty
concisely without any physiological
adaptations needed yeah uh the third
illusion in that I that I refer to in my
article is that calorie intake we view
it instantaneously right so when when we
bump our calories to 3000 a day we say I
eat 3 000 calories per day and we don't
really think about well what was my kind
of trajectory of calorie intake over the
last six months or over the last 12
months right so we we talk about calorie
intake in an instant instantaneous way
but body weight change and body
composition change is cumulative in
nature right so for example let's say
hypothetically you finish a diet you
accomplish your weight loss goal at the
end of the diet your energy expenditure
every day is 2600 calories a day and you
decide okay I'm just going to do a
maintenance phase and keep my intake at
2 600 calories 16 weeks later still
taking in 2600 calories you still weigh
the same again it's an
oversimplification that implies that
everything's static and never changes
but but that's where we're at
now let's say that you finish your diet
and your energy expenditure is still
2600 calories per day but you ended the
diet consuming
2225 calories a day right so you're in
debt you're in a deficit that makes
sense because you're losing weight right
so instead of just jumping to 2600 you
say I'm actually going to slowly build
this up over time right and so very
linearly in a stepwise manner every week
you make a change and you build up from
22 225 up to
2975 calories per day so you just keep
ramping it up at the end of that 16-week
period making a change at the beginning
of each week building up to 29.75 you're
thinking whoa when I compare this to the
alternative I've built up my metabolic
rate by almost 400 calories I'm
maintaining the same weight but instead
of eating 2600 calories per day I'm
eating 2975.
the reality is that both of those
strategies have the same cumulative
energy balance because during the first
part of that reverse diet
you were still in a fairly substantial
calorie deficit you didn't actually get
into neutral energy balance until about
halfway through it and then you know the
other half you know when you're looking
at that intake of 29.75 you are in a
small Surplus but you just got there and
so you have not had time to accumulate
that body fat so it's an Illusion by
which instead of just jumping to
maintenance if we ramp it up over 16
weeks it looks like we built up
metabolic capacity by 400 calories per
day but we can fully explain that with
math that requires no increase in energy
expenditure whatsoever those are two
mathematically equivalent approaches in
terms of the cumulative amount of energy
that would be stored yeah yeah uh now we
can look at another example where let's
say instead of trying to maintain you
say whatever I'm cool with a little bit
of weight gain right so you finish your
diet uh total energy expenditures 2600
calories per day and so you decide I'm
just going to bump up to 29.70 85 right
out of the gate so the last example
that's what you built up to in this case
you say whatever I'm fine with a little
a little bit of weight regain I'm gonna
bump up 29.75 every day 16 weeks
eventually you have a positive energy
balance over time of 42 000 calories of
extra calories coming in
now in a different scenario you can
start at the same place and say I'm
going to start at 2 2225 just like I did
in the last reverse dieting example
but I'm gonna ramp up very aggressively
the change I make every week is going to
be twice as big at the end of the six 16
week period I'm going to ramp all the
way up to 30 to
3725 calories we're talking about over 3
700 calories a day that is a massive
calorie intake for a lot of people so if
you take that approach instead and you
work up from 2225 up to
3725 you still have a cumulative energy
balance of 42 000 calories per day so
these two approaches jumping straight to
29.75 or working up to 37.25 the
cumulative impact on on energy balance
is the same so one person would look
back and say yeah I gained some weight
but uh I'm only eating 2 975 calories a
day the other person would say well I've
gained the same amount of weight but I'm
eating 3 700 like I've clearly built up
my metabolic capacity by 800 calories
that's not the case when we look at
these short time scales and these fixed
time scales we find that ramping your
way up can create this illusion
that your energy expenditure has
dramatically changed in the short term
it's difficult to see that but if people
continue this you know so in this
example you know the one person keeps
eating 29.75 the other person continues
building or stays at 3 700 calories a
day over time those body composition
differences are going to become very
substantial and very apparent and the
reason that's important is because I
often see anecdotes of people saying you
know I've been doing this reverse
dieting and
I'm just amazed at how lean I am at my
current calorie intake and it's almost
always people who have been ramping up
their calories over the last month or
two it's very rarely someone who says
yeah this is crazy I I've been doing
very meticulous tracking my entire
fitness journey and now for very long
time scales I just eat a thousand
calories more than I used to it's way
more rare to see that and it's
exceedingly more rare to see people say
yeah I did this in the off season and
now that I'm dieting it's a breeze
because again A lot of times that
initial inflation of energy intake is
actually more of an illusion than
anything and any metabolic changes that
actually do occur during that time
period probably go away the moment you
start dieting yeah or I mean to to the
extent where it's not an illusion like
and this is something we've talked about
off mic before but like I I think
um
I do think
reverse dieting can work not necessarily
for the reasons that are advertised but
as
kind of a trick to convince people to
actually be in a caloric Surplus for
once yeah uh like like people who are
trying to be super lean all the time
they're chronic dieters
and they they've never really given
themselves
a long-ish term energy Surplus to
actually like builds a muscle and be
able to train hard and not be super
fatigued like if you can convince them
oh yeah ramp up your calories gradually
you're not going to gain much fat which
if you told them on the front end like
oh yeah you totally are they wouldn't
listen to you in the first place right
so you you can kind of trick them into
actually getting into a surplus for a
while building muscle and then yeah
maybe their next diet does go better and
maybe their energy expenditure
is a little bit higher at the end of the
diet but it's not necessarily because
they quote unquote built up their
metabolic capacity due to the reverse
diet itself you just you just finally
tricked them to get into a surplus for
the first time in five years right and
uh you know the the bot the ability to
to build muscle and train hard from
getting in that Surplus uh was the thing
that helped them in their subsequent
weight loss phase yeah and another thing
you know like we mentioned previously it
kind of tricks people into saying well
we're gonna do even if it's not a
surplus if you say well we're gonna do a
maintenance phase but you're actually
going to really meticulously track a lot
of people very understandably so during
a maintenance phase they say oh cool
like this is a time I'll just make sure
body weight's pretty stable uh you know
when it starts drifting up I'll tighten
things up if it starts drifting down
I'll tighten things up and kind of
course correct and keep body weight
stable
um but in that in that context the
maintenance phase works fine
but people often often underestimate
their actual calorie intake during the
maintenance phase for a lot of people
it's the first time that they've
committed to a long maintenance phase
and actually gotten a very good accurate
quantification of how many calories they
eat during a maintenance phase yeah so
yeah that's definitely part of it uh and
then the final thing I want to mention
here is an illusion that involves an
inversion of cause and effect
because you know I mentioned previously
that when someone after a weight loss
diet goes
from an energy deficit to energy balance
there are real things that happen like
maintenance phases have physiological
impacts you know we we do see a small
partial restoration of total daily
energy expenditure for a lot of folks we
do see a partial or full attenuation of
some of those symptoms of relative
energy deficiency and in some people
this can create subject subjective
improvements in quality of life and just
how they feel that have really important
impacts on their activity level the way
that they train like going from a
deficit to a maintenance is a real
intervention that does real
physiological changes
and most importantly those have been
documented we look at the research and
say what happens when a person who's
been dieting goes to maintenance we can
look at actual evidence and say how it
affects how they feel their energy
expenditure the way they train their
activity level those are real things
that the physiology literature fully
accounts for one thing that we cannot
look at the literature for is saying
well but then what happens if I increase
my carbs by 10 grams every day yeah uh
there's no evidence to suggest that's a
physiological relevant intervention that
would do anything other than eventually
if you do it long enough and do some
extra weight gain right and so when I
talk about cause and effect the reason
this comes up is because a lot of times
people frame reverse dieting as well I
was at neutral energy balance right
at my low crappy post diet energy
expenditure but when I bumped my carbs
up 10 grams my body decided for some
reason contrary to everything we know
about weight regain and post diet fat
storage I am instead going to ramp up my
energy expenditure to match that why I
literally have no idea yeah but I'm
gonna do that and then that happens and
then you increase your carbs 10 grams
again and your body says again I have no
regard for the weight regain literature
I'm going to do a thing that's never
actually really been observed and bump
up again and match that and for some
reason this weight reduced body has
decided this is my my permanent body
weight and if you keep ramping up
calories I promise to keep increasing
energy expenditure to match it
that's never been observed and nothing
close to it has been observed uh
but what has been observed is that when
you go from a deficit to maintenance
energy expenditure does increase a
little bit
and so what I posit in this article
is that
reverse dieting is the effect of
establishing neutral energy balance it
is not the cause that is ramping up
energy expenditure so rather than saying
because I increase my carbs 10 grams my
body is elevating my energy expenditure
I think it works the other way around I
think it's I was dieting right and so my
energy expenditure was suppressed
when I went from negative to neutral
energy balance
all of a sudden all of a sudden I'm in
what we would call a maintenance phase
you know and I'm in neutral energy
balance and in response to that my
energy expenditure probably will go up a
little bit not all the way to where it
started but a little bit and we have
ample evidence to suggest that that
happens we're in the research again
we're not in the
imaginary world right
and so as a result oh wow I jumped to
maintenance and then my energy
expenditure bumped up a little bit and
actually over time because of that
it looks like my weight is actually
starting to drop just a tiny bit you
know and so because I have restored
neutral energy balance eventually I
actually have the opportunity in the
future to increase my carbs by 10 grams
just to get back to neutral energy
balance right so I started in this huge
deficit I closed that Gap and then my
energy expenditure creeps up a little
bit which has been observed and so now I
have to bump my my calories up a little
bit just to stay in neutral energy
balance and so what I believe is
happening based on the evidence is that
reverse dieting is this gradual increase
in calories is enabled by getting back
to approximately neutral energy balance
instead of staying in the deficit and so
what we see is yes
over time a person can gradually
increase their calories a little bit by
little bit by little bit and stay
relatively weight neutral over that time
period but it's not because the the 10
grams of carbs are doing something
special that's never been observed in
the literature it's because getting to
approximately maintenance is doing
something that absolutely has been
observed in literature and so we're able
to continue bumping calories up because
we are keeping Pace with an energy
expenditure that is very subtly climbing
because instead of being in this big
prolonged deficit we're doing our best
to stay in approximately neutral energy
balance and the analogy I draw on there
is related to uh uh Brian Miner and Eric
Helms and I don't know if they had other
authors on that paper
um they published a really insightful
article about uh basically how we view
Progressive overload with resistance
training right and so
um we don't need a maximal training
stimulus every workout to be able to
make adaptation we just we just need the
training stimulus to be good enough to
impose more adaptation and so they
basically say you know you're not doing
Progressive overload you're not causing
it by adding five pounds on the bar
what's happening is you're giving an
adequate training stimulus you're
getting stronger and you're adding five
pounds on the bar to make sure that the
the training stimulus continues to be
adequate so you're adding pounds on the
bar because you're getting stronger
versus every little minute change in
training load making this enormous
difference in terms of your progression
over time yeah so I think it's a
gymnastics just to state that another
way yeah adding five more pounds to the
bar doesn't force you to get stronger
yes you are able to add five more pounds
to the bar because you have already
gotten stronger exactly and in an
analogous way 10 grams of carbs is not
forcing your energy expenditure upward
to a meaningful degree you are able to
add in an additional 10 grams because
you have been instead of being in a debt
in a deficit you have gotten close to to
you know approximately neutral energy
balance and your energy expenditure is
responding in kind so uh those are the
four illusions that I think are
contributing to why we see so many of
these positive anecdotes and again they
are compelling they are convincing and I
do not fault anyone for for saying wow
this this really looks like it's doing
something as I mentioned simply being in
maintenance does real physiological
things compared to being in a deficit so
I'm not even saying that nothing's
happening during reverse dieting but
what I am saying is that reverse dieting
in most applications uh is really just a
more stressful mechanism of getting into
a maintenance phase or getting into
neutral energy balance which does
actually do things right so people might
experience
positive things during a reverse diet
but the only positive physiological
things going on that have that would
make sense in a reverse diet would also
be absolutely accomplished by simply
doing a maintenance phase and working up
to it slowly doesn't really seem to add
any benefit if you have a good estimate
of what your energy expenditure is at
the end of a diet you should be able to
jump straight to it and enjoy all of
those benefits of neutral energy balance
without delaying that process and kind
of saying well I'm going to stay in a
deficit and just bump up 10 grams at a
time until I get there right yeah so
one of the things that people often ask
um
on this topic
is like is there ever a reason to try
reverse dieting you know and we own
macro factor and for all the reasons I
just talked about for way too long we
don't have a reverse diet function
because frankly I
I don't think the evidence is there I
don't want to take users on this ride
where they spin their wheels and have
these really high expectations and
ultimately end up disappointed you know
it's
it's an evidence-based app and and we
want to make sure that we are providing
all the best features that we can
possibly provide that are also
compatible with the evidence right
um but people still ask like hey um you
know is there ever a reason to try
reverse dieting uh One Good Reason is
you're just curious and you want to try
it yeah there's nothing wrong with that
I I don't lose sleep over the idea that
someone out there is currently reverse
dieting right so if you're really
intriguing to really interested
absolutely you're welcome to it and we
design macro factor in a way that
enables that you know and we've got a
thing on the knowledge the knowledge
base that tells you how to do that but
basically just setting an extremely slow
weight gain goal it just provides that
little upward pressure on your calorie
Target boom you've done a reverse diet
but it's not some special feature that
we're willing to advertise and say hey
come check out this incredible new thing
that defies physiology right if you want
to try to just set the the lowest
possible rate of weight gain and see if
it nudges your calories upward you know
by all means if you're just interested
that's fine you can do it in macro
factor or you can do it without macro
Factor doesn't really matter
um but I think the most justifiable
scenario for why you might want to try
reverse dieting
is you just finished a fat loss phase
and you'd like to maintain you know
basically all of your weight loss in the
long term you're very adamant that you
don't want to regain weight uh your
energy intake your calorie Target at the
end of your diet is a bit unsustainable
for you so you're like okay I want to
maintain this physique exactly I don't
want to regain fat but I don't think I
can maintain this low calorie intake for
a long time uh but you also don't really
know what your total daily energy
expenditure is you know what you've been
eating and you know that it's been
promoting weight loss but you're not
really sure what your energy expenditure
is in that scenario there is a
possibility that just guessing your
energy expenditure and therefore your
target for calories in a maintenance
phase you could overestimate that energy
expenditure and therefore the calorie
Target uh and if it's a substantial
overestimation you might regain fat
because like we've said all the evidence
suggests that if you recently lost
weight you are physiologically primed
for some pretty efficient fat regain
right so in that scenario
I do think it makes sense
theoretically to say well instead of
making a guess that I don't feel good
about maybe I'll just slowly work up and
test the waters I'll keep those
Illusions previously mentioned in mind
and I'll try to settle on a maintenance
phase that's going to work for the long
term now
your energy expenditure might go up in
the process as you get more from a
deficit to neutral energy balance is
that going to make your next diet easier
probably not you'll probably still
experience metabolic adaptation next
time around once you get back into a
sizable energy deficit but it basically
the concept of reverse dieting functions
as a way to work toward a maintenance
Target when you're not certain of what
it is likely to be and you're very
adamant but you don't want to regain any
fat but I will also mention that one of
the reasons we don't offer that feature
in macro Factor aside from the lack of
evidence and the excessive hype that
comes with that term
is the fact that if you're using macro
Factor the guesswork is gone you know we
keep a very well calculated running
estimate of your total daily energy
expenditure so the moment you stop a
diet a weight loss diet and switch to
maintenance we're not just guessing you
know we we haven't we have empirical
data to indicate what your most likely
maintenance Target is we put you there
and then we have a dynamic uh
maintenance approach where if your
energy expenditure does start creeping
up because you've gone from a deficit to
neutral energy balance
the app will pick up on that in your
weight Trend and it will increase your
calorie Target so basically again the
reverse dieting might occur you know in
the sense that calories might creep up
over time but that's the effect of the
maintenance phase not something that is
causing this
previously unidentified physiological
effect yeah right yeah
so
um I think that pretty much does it I
just want to wrap up with some practical
applications uh there's really no
evidence to suggest that reverse dieting
accomplishes anything more than a fairly
standard maintenance phase
um when it comes to metabolic adaptation
this is not something that stops weight
loss in its tracks it's not something
that guarantees weight regain and so
what we should be trying to do is simply
quantify it and account for it so as
you're dieting it's nice to see how your
expenditure is changing so that you can
simply keep either making calorie
adjustments to accommodate it or extend
your weight loss timeline to accommodate
it because both of those options should
be effective based on the actual
research in human beings losing weight
and that is really what we use to guide
our the way we approach things in macro
factor or to or to use it as an
indication to maybe try to increase
activity levels yes yeah that is
absolutely another way that you could uh
account for metabolic adaptation but
we're not trying to totally stifle it or
circumvent it or fix it or anything like
that because you know as we've talked
about the the available evidence does
not really leave wiggle room for the
concept that reverse dieting is going to
you know really effectively and robustly
and persistently reverse these things
so if you're interested in Reverse
dieting just because you're curious or
because you want to transition to a
long-term maintenance phase and you
don't know what your target should be I
do think it's justifiable but for most
cases I think just a pretty simple
maintenance phase should be
should be good enough to get the job
done there and based on the evidence a
maintenance phase can be a really
positive thing but there's really no
evidence of and really no evidence
supporting the theoretical Concepts that
reverse dieting should really be any
more effective than a maintenance phase
well based on where this segment started
uh when you asked me what good things I
thought reverse dieting would do for me
personally uh I have to say that I'm
very upset with how this segment went
you've dashed all of my hopes upon the
Rocks but I will try to be strong and uh
adapt to this very unfortunate
information that you're giving me well I
I appreciate your resiliency uh in the
face of this bad news
um one closing comment that I want to
reiterate in this segment I talked about
how
we approach these types of things in
macro Factor uh and the reason is we
developed the app to accommodate
challenges in you know the process of
trying to gain weight lose weight
maintain weight Etc so uh it's really
important to recognize you can take all
this information and use it and never
spend a cent on macro factor and that's
fine you don't need macro factor to
apply any of this information
um and yeah like I like like we said
previously uh the the purpose here was
not to sell you on macro Factor it was
just a kind of
readjust the public perception of
reverse dieting because it seems to have
just taken on a life of its own and
gotten so far from the evidence that we
really do need to rein it back in a
little bit
um
yeah so uh there's uh you don't need
macro factor to make any of this
information useful and as we mentioned
previously my only conflicts of interest
would lead me to say actually
reverse dieting very effective in fact
find the first study that ever mentioned
it it's mine I'm a Visionary and also
let's throw it in the app and Market it
and make a bunch of money off of it uh
but we haven't done that and uh to be
very to be very honest
it would have been way quicker and
easier to just put it in the app than to
write the 60-page article explaining why
it's not in the app you know uh it's
just we don't believe in it you know and
so that that's why we don't have it yeah
uh but I will say if the evidence comes
around and I have to eat my words and
say actually 2014 Eric was way smarter
than 2022 Eric we can always put it in
well I mean if anything it's more
grotesque than that because initially
you put forth the idea of reverse
dieting and to be clear I didn't make it
up I was the first person to mention it
in a peer-reviewed paper yeah but you
know you did that and now in this
article you are you're publicly eating
crow but to extend the metaphor you're
going to have to figure out how to
regurgitate The Crow and bring it back
to life Dr Frankenstein style yeah
um
and if you know we'll cross that bridge
when we get there yeah I'll put together
a narrative about like you know what you
gotta you gotta stick to your guns I let
the haters get in my head I let them
convince me that I I wasn't actually a
beautiful genius but indeed I am so
we'll go back